just another day just another million
subscribers let's check how much money
my last video made
what what this is not a drill that's
right it's me Dylan the hacker and if
you're watching this I can't click away
then my plan has succeeded if you're
watching this then I have officially
hacked into a live PewDiePie video how
is this possible how the [ __ ] did he
hack me
hello pro army today's the day you learn
to respect Big Daddy Dylan the
professional hacker never I will never
shed a sprint of respect for you Dylan
not after what you did that's right I'm
going shirtless for this one oh yeah
well two can play that game nothing gay
about that Australian outback style baby
I just had the biggest YouTube channel
in the world well tag into mine
you see me in all my glory another I've
hacked a PewDiePie video I have just one
thing to say one thing to tell the
entire world pretty much Jenna belongs
to me now
no dad me bro army oh y'all listening to
me never me into this you made me what I
am
well when me ah what the [ __ ] did he
just spray-paint his [ __ ] face
this is the Ranger Khalid [ __ ] City hack
me do you see this chair do you why do
you have to hack me you knew hacking was
my biggest weakness you know how to play
this game this is only the beginning
grow our me because when I knew hacking
technique I will be able to insert
myself into any PewDiePie video from now
on you'll never know when or where I
might show up this is on to begin
oh my god a new hacking technique a new
technique has been uncovered well you're
not the only one that has a trick or two
up his sleeve I know the ultimate
hacking move of all time and he follows
me on Twitter
of course
it looks like it's time it's working my
god it's dangerous if this continues I
could die
I'm so [ __ ] hard right now the vape
God is on my side yo
all right gross it looks like I'm in for
the [ __ ] am i Matthew McConaughey is
that you you crying are you crying like
a little bit Matthew I don't want your
subs don't worry
now help me help me find the other side
I said I'll come back for you tonight
all right
I'm trying hacking again this time it
should work I hacked the wrong channel
again god damn it why does this feel
very similar to the PewDiePie channel
but still not really my color reminds me
of like PewDiePie or something
is it working did it work
yes I'll thank God we're back Oh Dylan
the hacker you may look sexy as [ __ ] but
you got nothing on these why don't we
take this next battle into AI our air
cuz it's about to [ __ ] it's about to
slam it out we're gonna slam it out
we're gonna slam it out dude [ __ ] yet I
beat you loser
piece of trip zero
Oh